hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and I was recently reading over
the patreon page for mindscape and I
noticed that the very first sentence in
the description says I'm a scientist
author and now a podcaster so think
about that move the very first way that
I'm introducing potential patreon
patrons to the mindscape podcast is to
talk about myself by giving myself
labels right scientist author podcaster
this is the move of identity of labeling
ourselves as part of a larger group and
this idea of identity has become
contentious in the modern world it
probably was always contentious right
what identities matter what is the role
of identity in particular we have the
idea of identity politics which arranges
people on kind of a spectrum there's one
spectrum that says look if I am you know
female or African American or poor these
are incredibly important aspects about
myself and politically it makes all the
sense in the world to organize along
those lines that I can share my
interests with other people who share
that identity on the other side of the
spectrum there is a move that says we
should all be citizens of the world we
should all be common human people we
should take our identities and try to
put them aside for the greater good
and I know I'm trying to say this in a
very unobjectionable way many many
people rush to one of the ends of this
spectrum and then caricature people on
the other end today's conversation is an
attempt to move beyond these caricatures
and take the idea of identity seriously
in the context of politics but also just
in the context of how we live our lives
how we think about ourselves
my guest is Kwame Anthony Appiah who is
a very distinguished philosopher and
also someone who has a lot of identities
that play important roles in the modern
world he was born and raised in Ghana he
was educated in the UK in prestigious
places like Cambridge University he now
lives in New York City he is gay and
biracial and most of all he's a
philosopher these are all identities
that are very
important he's written a wonderful book
on cosmopolitanism which is sort of the
idea that we should in some sense try to
look beyond our identities and be part
of this bigger picture but he argues
that that doesn't mean erasing our
identities we have to learn to live with
our identities while acknowledging that
to a large extent they're made up right
if you are black or Asian or white in
the modern world this is a crucially
important part of your identity if
you're black-haired or brown haired or
red-haired that is a less important part
for basically arbitrary reasons so what
are the aspects of identity that matter
how can we use them to live together how
do we construct them what are the
stories we tell these are the topics
we're going to be talking about in
today's podcast remember you can get
complete transcripts for everything that
we say here at the mindscape podcast
just go to the web page preposterous
universe comm slash podcast and at the
end of the episode blog post there'll be
a little link that says click here for
the transcript the whole transcript will
be there so you can actually search the
entire webpage to find anything that has
ever been talked about on the mindscape
podcast and with that let's go
[Music]
while my Anthony Appiah welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm delighted to be
talking to you I'm gonna start with an
anecdote which will seem a little bit
out of left field but hopefully it will
connect back into what we're talking
about my wife and I were watching Castle
Rock which is a TV show based on Stephen
King's stories and there's a mother and
daughter characters this season who
shared this story about the laughing
place and that seemed vaguely familiar
to me but I didn't know it so I went of
course online like googled it
so the laughing place comes from the
Brer Rabbit stories the Brer Rabbit
story is familiar to many Americans
through Uncle Remus and and things like
that so of course I'm on Wikipedia and I
click on Brer Rabbit to you know
jog my memory about those stories turns
out I had never known this Brer Rabbit
sort of as a trickster figure his
stories were translated from West Africa
where they were stories of a non-si the
spider and so I clicked on a non-si the
spider who's also in a different TV show
these days on American Gods Neil Gaiman
TV show and I'm reading about a non-si
the spider in his exploits when I see
that you know one of the major academic
works about a non-si de spider one of
the major collections was compiled by
Peggy ah Pia who I believe is your
mother right yes yes yeah so she
collected actually she also published a
Nancy stories believe it okay
yeah which she'd written well she got
the first volume was called tales have
been a santa father and my father being
a Santee grew up with Nancy stories
which are still very much known and he
told some of them to us and she was
listening and she thought they were kind
of cool so she started writing them down
and adapting them in the way you do when
you write things and so she so her first
books were children's stories based on
uh Nancy stories and one of them I don't
think any of them did one of them have
the word announcing the title I can't
remember but as I say the first was
called tales of Musante father and then
so that was one kind of tradition that
she collected but the other thing she
collected were these things that are
called gold weights which are not made
of gold with a
for weighing gold and there are made of
brass and some of them are figurative
and some of them have abstract designs
on them and actually you can tell
roughly when they were made by what
kinds of designs they have because
depending on whether they were trading
with Europeans or with Arabs they have
different weighting systems and so on so
there's a they're full of interesting
information about culture but she
started collecting those she was trained
as an artist who went to art school and
became one of the world's experts on
them and she would of course what she
did was she took them to people often in
villages and asked them to talk about
them and the way they talked about them
often was by telling proverbs many of
which are in fact the taglines of a
nancy story so how she started
collecting proverbs and we published
translations of seven and a half
thousand proverbs that she collected in
my father's language so it's a bilingual
edition of the of the problems with
glosses which of course took a very long
time to make an Imagine yeah but it
struck me as so appropriate because we
wanted to talk today about identity and
cosmopolitanism and one of the things
I've heard you say is how stories help
feed into the identity of a people and
and also there's questions of
appropriation and translation and for
that matter the fact that the Anansi
stories to the extent that they were
converted into Brer Rabbit stories were
then appropriated by Walt Disney from
that movie the song of the south which
gave you the impression that being a
slave was a wonderful happy thing and so
there's a lot of issues that really just
flow right out of that single anecdote
oh yes yes no I think the Anansie
stories are that they're part of a wider
genre of trickster stories which include
things like the Loki in the Indian in
the Norse Sagas and to some extent some
of the characters in the Greek mythology
but and then there but there are very
important ones in West Africa the other
large sort of tradition is Yoruba
tradition and
issue whose the tricks to go there is a
very important figure in their mythology
and and and sort of theology and what's
interesting about them in these all
these traditional cultures is I'm in a
way you could say that Ulysses is a kind
of trickster figure the role of annoyed
everybody he's a hero he's annoying
so the idea idea that the trickster is
is very powerful and important is a very
widespread cross-cultural notion and
Anansie stories are not all about a
Nancy and Nancy a nancy s/m which is the
word just mean which just mean or Santee
well it means a Nancy things or a Nancy
words or something is the generic term
for all folktales so there are there are
Nancy stories in which Nancy isn't it
doesn't occur but but a lot of them are
about him and he's asleep he's a spider
trickster and and so the idea that you
respect maybe a little bit fear but also
admire the trickster figure is is a
central thing that you're brought up
with if you're brought up with these
stories well is it too much to think
that the kinds of stories let me ask you
a question how much do the kinds of
stories that different communities and
groups of people lean on either reflect
who they are or shape who they become is
that an even an answerable question well
I think those kinds of questions of
causality a rather hard to tease out but
that but reflect sure I mean I think and
I think it must be the case that if
you're brought up to with these stories
in which a Nancy is a focus and admired
it must so there's something to you
about what in in my father's in English
in garner is called Krishna's he was
very tricky issue people say
so I think it must do and I think and
certainly you know when we think about
the role of the novel in shaping that
moral climate of societies as it surely
must have as also it reflected them you
know it provides these stories provide a
way of thinking about questions that
arise for you the questions about I mean
in the 19th century questions about
marriage and property are you know
they're real questions for the kind of
people that read Trollope novels the
people we're making decisions all the
time about about that sort of thing and
to have stories in which it works out or
it doesn't work out it stories that
essentially teach the idea that love is
tremendously important and that all the
marriage stuff that is also important
but for property related reasons can get
in the way of this other important thing
I mean that's you know I think that's
part of a long history that changes the
character of marriage eventually and
John Stuart Mill who's on the wall there
you know rather Stern right look he's
very stern no but there's David Hume
behind it yes yes male you know Mill's
discussions of their connection to
marriage and equality in on the
subjection of women you know the part of
that depends upon the longer history of
the growth of ideas about romantic love
and the importance of romantic love and
the idea of companionship in marriage as
opposed to co-parenting as being the
main thing you do and and the bringing
together of individuals rather than of
families being the main thing to do and
so all of that surely must have been
affected by people reading reading the
novels of romance and anti-romance
so I think the stories that people read
and and and the stories that they hear
as they're growing up the stories that
are told must have a big impact yeah and
and I know that's why it's important to
read the children's write and to tell
them stories if you don't read well I
think so that's let's actually even this
is this is
reflecting bigger issues right I mean we
need to get some of the bigger issues on
the table words like identity are very
charged these days and there's different
senses of identity right our racial
identity our national identity and so
forth how do you have a simple way of
just thinking about what the word
identity means or how it's used these
days
that depends on what you mean by simple
I don't need to be too thankful this is
I mean you like to get a little high I
think so first of all it's very
important that this way of using the
word identity is an entirely per second
world war phenomena it's a modern
phenomenon people did not use the word
identity and this is very hard to find a
word that does the same job before so
the idea that race and gender and
nationality and religion are all things
of the same kind which I mean I'm we're
so used to that idea that you set back
for everything
Wow you know is that really true well
actually you know that's that it's I
don't want to go over that too quickly
because that's that's really worth
pointing out so the identity before
Second World War would have just been
more individual like who used yes I mean
they wouldn't have used the word
identity they would have used words like
self or individual or I mean there's
lots of language for talking about some
of the group members and so on also it
was like though ethnicity is a
relatively modern word to words like
that
so not only our identities constructed
but identity identity was conferred
what's constructed is the idea that all
of these are the same and here's his so
now here's my answer to the question
what what you know why are they all the
same they're all the same in these
because they all have the following
three properties one they know labeling
and without the labeling become work to
theirs they mean something to the
bearers of the label so that they say to
themselves they get up in the morning
and they do things because they're men
no because they're black or because
they're worried or because they're
Catholic and three other people do
things to them because of the labels so
that's the basic structure of of the
identity labeling and there's one other
thing that's that should be said as
where as part of the basic theory as
well I think which is that all of these
things tend to be contested
so exactly who are the men and who are
the women as we've now noticed is not as
obvious as people have taken it to be
and now we have contests about that what
it means to me to be black or gay or
whatever is I mean I may not be entirely
clear about that other people may have
views about what it means to me that I
don't share other people may tell me
that I'm not being black enough or that
I'm letting down the gay community being
gay right well being the right way and
also this huge obviously disagreement
about you know sometimes if at all we
should take notice of people's
identities when we were interacting with
them but if we if we should how should
we so some peeps so here's a practice
which I noticed when I came to this
country which is the non-white people in
small towns who don't know each other
and I was always one of them because
they didn't know me will often just
greet you you're already in a club
they'll just say hello yeah and and the
white people won't they're not hostile
they just they just don't think it's
appropriate to talk to a stranger every
strangers on the street and that's now
some dude is that appropriate right
people can think well that's kind of
weird after all as it turns out I know
almost nothing of the culture of the
people who were I mean I do now but I
didn't then know very much about the
culture of the people who were greeting
me and and who knows whether I wanted to
be greeted as it were they didn't know
anything about how grumpy I might be so
it seems mostly sweet it seems sweet but
if notice that if white people made a
habit of doing this in a mixed-race town
people might begin to think that that
was a bad thing now that's something to
do with the fact that white people are
going to be
Georgiy and if if they if they were a
minority in a small town again we might
think that that's not so surprising even
even given the background of racism and
the fact that that you know building
cross racial relations is probably
things in this country we ought to care
about doing well than we do but many
cities have expat communities right
where foreigners or strangers stick
together and say yes and in fact one
interesting thing for Americans I think
is that when Americans go abroad
Americans who are very conscious of the
things that divide them from each other
when they're at home come to spend time
together and wrecking and also become
commonly defensive of things that they
might well criticize when they're back
home so you know this is an important
point about the contextual character of
what identities do for us it depends on
what the background is let me pause for
a second to talk about blankest which is
a wonderful app you can download for
your phone your tablet your web browser
that gives you a quick convenient way of
getting information from thousands of
non-fiction books blinka steaks the best
key takeaways the need-to-know
information and condenses it down to
about 15 minutes worth of reading that
you can either read in the words or you
can just listen to it 12 million people
are using bleakest right now and has a
massive and growing library my very
first guest here on mindscape carol
terrace her book mistakes were made but
not by me is on blankest my second guest
Carlo Rovelli has several different
books on blinkin
you can both use it to get the essence
of books you might just want to skim or
even better use it to sample lots of
books that you might figure out these
are the ones I want to dig into fully
right now for a limited time plinkus has
a special offer just for mindscape
listeners go to blankest dot-com slash
mindscape to try it for free for seven
days and also get 25% off a new
subscription that's blinka spelled b li
NK IST plinkus comm slash mindscape to
start your seven day free trial and get
25% off
and I like I like your definition
because it highlights the extent to
which the identity is not simply from
within ourselves it's so shaped by how
we interact with the rest of the world
and how they interact with us that's
right in fact sometimes identities are
sort of forged by common enemies yes yes
I mean Charles Taylor says that they're
dialogical I like that word because
because if you're part of what that
means is it if you're gonna change them
or shift them around you've got to get
everybody on board and it it may be that
you might have a view that the insider's
views about how things how a certain
identity should work should we give an
extra weight but in general identities
are part of a system of identities and
so everybody has a stake in it you can't
change what it means to be a woman and
just leave what it is to be a man
completely free-floating ly
independently in fact when you draw a
boundary it separates two things two
things
and and so the agreements about where
the boundary lies are obviously required
as well the consent of all parties or at
least the only can be settled if you can
get the consent of all parties and and
similarly the meanings of these things
they're they're socially available
meanings when you you know if you're a
parent and you have a male child and a
female child the way in which their
gender identities are available to them
is going to depend on more than just
what you think and more than what they
come to think it's going to depend on
how people in the world think about
those things and different people in the
world may think differently so it's very
much a matter I think of it as something
that inevitably involves negotiation and
perhaps compromise because a change in
the system that is very good for some
people maybe may actually take something
away from other people now it may be as
in the case of the changes in the gender
system you know produced by kind of the
kind of feminism that goes back to John
Stuart Mill and
and Mary Wollstonecraft those changes
took away some things some privileges
from men and a jolly good thing to I
mean so sometimes what's taken away from
people they weren't entitled to but
still they lost something and so you had
to make it really work you had to get
them on board and I think this is
something that I feel is a little bit
missing in the discussions about trans
issues is the recognition that is an
issue for cysts people as well as trans
people and and that though the system
needs to be changed in ways that will
allow trans people better lives they
can't do it without bringing the rest of
us along yeah and that means they have
to make arguments they can't just
declare things and they have to help us
understand what it is they will not just
be annoyed with us for not understanding
it and so on no I mean so I agree with
the main thrust of what they're up to
but I think sometimes people behave as
if the resistance that comes to what
they want is it maybe unreasonable but
it's not it comes from a place of people
genuinely having a stake in the sister
and system and therefore having I think
the right to participate in in trying to
understand what's going on well and this
is one of the issues that inevitably
comes up when one such group one such
identity has been historically
discriminated against there are things
that they want and they're a little bit
impatient and one can forgive them for
being impatient right now they should
make merry I don't want to sit and
listen to write detailed arguments one
way or the other or even let me put it
even more strongly than that right they
can see what one person sees as a
dispassionate philosophical argument one
way or the other as an attack on who
they are yes and they do and and and it
may be but what I was arguing I suppose
is that you can't always get what you
know yeah and and that and that you know
you have to it's very look it's a very
interesting thing how
I think young people people in their
sort of teens and 20s today may have a
hard time understanding why lesbian and
gay people in the 50s and 60s and maybe
before were not just mad at their
families and not just angry with them
all the time in and kind of saying you
know take it or leave it this is Who I
am but they but that is what happened
people people negotiated with their
families and they they and when their
families reacted badly to coming out
they didn't stomp out of the room and
leave they stuck around and patiently at
average story there are lots of lots of
stories away from the mode but so I
think what works it turns out isn't
insisting immediately on getting your
rights even though they are your rights
what works is a little bit of patience
and and working with people to get them
to see what is what may be difficult for
them to see because and is too easy
perhaps for you to see because you are
living it you're living a trans identity
and it's it's clear to you what's going
on I think another thing to be said is
that the negotiation isn't just with sis
people it's not as if all trans people
have the same views about everything
just as anymore any more than gay people
or black people or white people or
anybody Catholics you know people have
disagreements within the tribe and again
you you you can declare somebody to be
doing the wrong thing as far as the
tribe goes but that isn't the way of
persuading anybody simply stipulating
that they're misbehaving and that the
black people shouldn't do that or gay
people shouldn't do that or whatever or
that you know you're letting down the
truth of the tribe so I think the the
dialogical is a good word
if if we see them as as a dialogue with
other people
and if we see that everybody has a stake
in it even if the stakes are much bigger
for some people and others still
everybody has a stake because it's a
system of identities and the meaning of
the identities like all meanings is a
common possession like the meanings of
words yeah you can't simply you know
like I'm too young just declare a word
to mean something if you want a word to
mean something or if you want to shift
the sense of a word you're gonna have to
work with people and they may or may not
go along
yeah well this that's an excellent
example it's very contemporary but I
like you know in your recent book the
lies that bind was that your most recent
book you got a lot of books and the the
the allusion in the title is to the fact
that in some sense identity is a lie
right or at least it's something we make
up it's a story but they do bind us
together and you do a wonderful job of
sort of going through different
modalities so what identity is so maybe
let's get that on the table as some
examples we can wrong race is the most
obvious one in the world right and it's
it's very interesting that this idea
that the word identity just wasn't used
before in this sense but certainly the
idea of racial identity was used and you
tell this wonderful story of this 18th
century philosopher who was was at a
time I guess before our current versions
of racial identity were quite congealed
yes and he was born in what is now gone
I whereas where I grew up but ended up
as a professor of philosophy in Germany
and it's a bit unclear under what terms
he got there but he because it looks
like he was a gift to he literally was
literally given given to this German
duco family but is that the kind of
thing that would have happened to white
children also no no I mean I I so
there's some unclarity about whether he
was technically a slave and the extent
to which his own family sort of agreed
to all this but we know that his brother
was enslaved and sent to Suriname
okay in the Dutch West Indies so when
did the slave trade start I'm sorry that
may well it starts in the 17th century
but it really reaches its peak a little
bit after the time that Adama was taken
from gardening in the mid 18th century I
suppose this is a transatlantic slave
trade there it's all over the world of
course so he and and this is sort of
early enlightenment and these and and
these are the people who had live knits
as the librarian there's this ducal
family there's around stuff going around
and they did an experiment they raised
they he was made that godson of two
dukes of them two of the children of the
Duke and and so he was called downtown
vilhelm after his his he's got parents
Antonin built homes and they he got the
education they go now they weren't gonna
become academics they became to become
aristocrats but that meant he ended up
with a law degree and a philosophy
degree and and as and then teaching and
made a living eventually as a teacher of
philosophy and was apparently well
respected and he wrote he wrote an
unfortunately lost book unfortunately
lost book because it's a book about the
lore of slavery and you'd love to know
it would have been an 18th century
African who'd become a German thought
about the law of slavery and we know a
little bit of the argument of it because
a lot of you know in the Enlightenment a
lot of some books got brief summaries
and encyclopedias on so we know
something about what he arguably would
be wonderful to have the whole thing but
we do have a textbook a philosophy right
which is actually rather good and
contains in particular some very good
arguments I think against de cartes
dualism which so now some people using
those arguments if they're teaching
historical course is to talk about some
of these things anyway so sorry I get a
positive that also I am an anti
Cartesian duelist and my favorite
arguments against his dualism
back in those days come from Princess
Elizabeth of Bohemia
another sort of member of an identity
which was not given she could not have
become a philosophy that's right
time but and I wonder if there's any
connection between you know slightly
other
identities and rejecting Cartesian
dualism I just made that up but no it's
a good idea and and I I will I will pass
it on to colleagues who work in that
area because as I say both both
Elizabeth and and now who are now taught
Jordan in the in a way that they weren't
even when I was in college so I would
people knew about her but you didn't
think in an introductory course or even
in a advanced course you wouldn't think
it was important to address her
arguments so so anyway so part of the so
what's the experiment what's the
experiment they're doing presumably part
of the experiment is can someone like
this achieve intellectual eminence okay
hypothesis proved right he can I'm sorry
the idea that he was a member of a
certain kind of person that was not a
Salesman
yeah that's it what what is the kind of
person that he was and I think the only
thing I think I want to say about that
is it's a complicated issue is that um
that that issue was being settled about
then that the idea of how race was going
to work at least in the context of
relations between Europeans and Africans
was being settled about there and it was
unsettled and in a way people who who
quoted um who's an example later on and
including you know the abbe Gregoire and
at the time of the French Revolution
really part of their playing what he was
used to argue was you know they're
pretty much like us mhm and so this idea
that this is a great cleavage in the
human species probably isn't so
important but so by the but by the end
of the 18th century by David Humes time
said this moment Hume says about I think
Francis Williams who was a Jamaican poet
did he can't have been any good because
he's black
and Kant says similar things though he
reversed himself eventually because
despite his rationalism Kant was
actually quite responsive to actual
evidence when when people like had a
pointed out to him that he was wrong
about these things he thought about in
change his mind but so the idea that
this there were these I mean again the
new idea is that that the natural
history of man which is not yet biology
but is something a bit before biology
answers the question of the kinds of man
that there are kinds of man is obviously
an ancient idea you just have to read
you know the beginning of the of the
Iliad to see lots of different kinds of
Greeks and also Greeks and Trojans these
are different kinds of people and in the
background of Persian so we're another
kind of people and Ethiopians who are
another kind of people you know the gods
are off feasting with the blameless
Ethiopians at the beginning of the Iliad
so what's new is the idea that there's
what we can think of as a kind of
protest scientific account of these
things because the standard account in
Christian Europe until then of the kinds
of man was it was a biblical account so
the descendants of Noah ham Shem Japheth
Shem for the Semites ham for the hay
mites and Japheth for the Drava sites
that is Europeans essentially that was
the idea now it's taken and of course
the biblical scheme has a problem which
is that it doesn't know about India and
China if there's a bunch of girls for
sure yeah and it's so it lacks full
completeness and so the idea that well
we should go looking and and that and
this is a matter for study and remember
this is this this is the century of
Linnaeus when Linnaeus who called us
Homo sapiens and gave us a Genesis and a
species and that idea again this part of
the proto scientific stuff in the 19th
century the science of biology really
grows up the word biology was actually
coined in 1800 in German
and and by the end of the century
actually about the beginning of the 20th
century the the account in terms of
genetics is beginning we think of Mendel
as having invented the basic ideas of
genetics and he did or at least I mean
he's the earliest person we know that we
had did experiments testing hypotheses
about genetic stuff but his work was
published but no and so it was really it
was really Morgan the dis awful a guy in
the early twentieth century the first
Nobel laureate in medicine I think who
who really got genex out there and and
the word genetics gets gets coined and
so on once you have a picture of how
biological inheritance works however you
can immediately see that because it's
particular to the idea that there's just
one thing being transmitted the race
doesn't look so easy to maintain and
already by 1911 just after the invention
of genetics WB Dubois you know who has a
degrees from the University of Berlin
has khalaf qualifications from the
university of berlin and harvard and so
on is highly educated so she'll just and
historian philosopher is saying this
shows that this old way of thinking is
not biological right so we've got a
biology of inheritance but it doesn't
map into the into the biology that we
thought we had for race I mean it's very
interesting because we see the concept
of the different races growing up and
and science is coming on the scene
contemporaneously and immediately put to
work yes yes but it's never a perfect
fit right it never necessarily does what
you want it to do and it's hard to
objectively follow what the science is
trying to tell you and you have these
people ride ideas I think the you know
in natural history it was a perfectly
reasonable hypothesis that there were
distinct varieties of human beings as
there are distinct varieties
crows and they're certainly shown legal
differences yeah right right and and
that that these were inherited was a
reasonable hypothesis though
interestingly enough the distinction
between biological and non-biological
inheritance really depends upon having a
genetic theory so if you until you have
a genetic theory the very idea of a
distinction between different ways of
transmitting things between the
generations is not really very well
theoretically articulated and you see
that in in in the characterization of
the races in in the late 18th century
and into the 19th century often things
that we would think I was obviously
cultural like beards you get get ready
get sort of treated as part of the story
and so this sort of the typical lap
Landa sort of was a one of the minor
races as it were is either going to be
bearded or not I didn't I don't actually
know what the answer is to that but so
so you need you need the new sense of
well the new sensibility which is
developed in the 19th century and which
develops in etics in the early 20th
century to get a clearer grip on what
the question is until then it's not
entirely clear what the question is so
as I said you know there have been kinds
of people all along there
Helene's and and Ethiopians and Persians
but in Hebrews and Philistines and so on
what's new is the idea that first that
this is a scientific question and then
that the right science is a science
that's now called biology which is a
very important thing because it puts the
question into the hands of the
scientists who are also supposed to be
classifying all the other organisms so
it takes it away from as it where the
distinctive the human sciences
anthropology say though anthropology is
very preoccupied with non-human animals
too in the beginning especially the
other primates but it's a it's a
question that gets reshaped as the
sciences
and as often happens in in the sciences
there are people who are just trying to
get it right
mm-hm and then there are people who
having an eye to what the concept is
doing in the world or trying to oh yeah
bring those things together and going
away the engine with it right right
and I think that you know what one of
them this is a sort of philosophy of
science point I suppose but one of the
reasons why it's really important to
have people of different identities
doing science or any intellectual
activity it's because the stakes for you
people are different and unfortunately
or unfortunately or unfortunately our
biases which we do not have strong
conscious control of are affected by
what the stakes are for us yeah so it
you know just if you think about how
many silly things were said by women
about women by 19th century male
scientists who were studying women in
various ways including that for example
the invention of hysteria and as a
psychiatric condition it would have been
much better if they'd been screwin
around who just said wait a minute you
know I'm gonna test I'm gonna push that
hypothesis I'm gonna test I brought this
because it doesn't seem very flattering
to people like me and they wouldn't even
have to say that explicitly then that
would have gone on you know explicitly
or not so I think the I mentioned two
boys one of the important things of
course that happens in the 20th century
in the scientific discussion these
questions is that more NAM people who
are not European of European Christian
ancestry get involved more they're more
african-americans in sociology and
through the through the 20th century
obviously more women as well also
importantly because of the way race gets
taken up by by remind the Nazis and by
European anti-semitism because remember
hostility to the jews pre-exists the
idea that they're a race in the modern
sense into goes back to your
- medieval anti-judaism because of that
the presence of significant numbers of
Jewish scientists I think in in life and
social sciences as well as of course in
the Natural Sciences generally was an
important break on some of the ways this
was going and produced so that the some
of the big statements on race that were
organized by people at UNESCO some of
the leading scientists involved with
Jewish scientists and I don't think
that's contingent because again the
stakes are different for different
people I mean yeah it's it's it's very
hard certainly both race and gender in
science when people try to talk about
who has abilities and who doesn't
people are really bad at separating you
know what they want to be true from what
is true on both sides yes I'm sure we
could talk about race for many hours or
and people have but maybe we could
contrast it with national identity is
certainly another very very strong kind
of identity and it which seems a priori
a totally different kind of thing Gary I
think I think they get conflated of
course I just mentioned the Nazis their
form of nationalism was a nationalism
about the German race the German people
understood as a race the the focus as
race are they very explicitly genetic
about that yeah I mean that's why they
did those things which like all the
experiments in the concentration camps
they were looking for biologically based
differences between real Germans and and
Jews Gypsies few a few poor black people
who got caught up in that system and so
on so they can get all muddled together
and what is certainly true is that
modern European nationalism which is
essentially the form of nationalism that
went global because of the role of
European empires in spreading these
ideas though it's affected by things in
other places but the core ideas start
out in Europe and they start out
essentially I think
from an intellectual point of view with
German intellectuals people like how de
you know and Gottfried Hauser and he so
he's full of nationalism is tied to the
idea of a people a Falk hater
how do you know and and that goes into
Hegel and Pagels are being a big wheel
in all of this stuff so the idea that
that that you should sort of map States
into into folks States into people's
that's sort of one of the great ideas of
nineteenth-century nationalism and
what's odd is that the process begins
the idea that people should be brought
together into a single state who are all
German or Slav or Italian or French
arises at a time when that's just so far
from the truth that you begin to
remember how untrue it is
german-speaking peoples are scattered
all over what's now Germany but other
places as well
so we're thinking here about 19th
century yes in the nineteenth century
even in the 1860s and 70s in France say
a third of the population I think didn't
speak French so the idea that there was
a natural group of called the people who
had a shared language culture and
traditions and were shared people which
increasingly gets turned to the idea of
a shared race because of the rise of
biology in the 19th century that idea is
sort of crazy faced with the reality of
Europe at the time in Italy is even
worse
Italy is worse they're very different
from those lots of different languages
very different traditions even you know
different sort of stereotypical looks
the typical Madonna is a you know sort
of descended from
the same people as many Northern
Europeans and typical Sardinian isn't
but anyway so nevertheless this idea
grabs hold and the idea that that
people's should map into States and that
they we should create a nation state
where the nation is both a political
thing and ER and the natural people
develops through the 19th century and
takes hold and and and the idea that
it's some natural unity but maybe not a
natural unity of blood
perhaps a natural unity created by
shared history and common traditions it
doesn't have to be doesn't have to be a
race-based thing but anyway some shared
thing and the point is any candid that
you give for the shared thing I'm gonna
be able to tell you a nineteenth-century
story about how that really would be
accepted right lots of exact but it
speaks to the the lure of the idea that
it was such a powerful force to create
and it meets an important need because
what's going on from another point of
view in the 19th century is the growth
of powerful state capacities and and
those state capacities depend upon state
istic they depend upon gathering the
numbers that states need in order to do
the things they do so censuses grow up
in our Constitution as a census built
into it in the late 18th century but
censuses get developed increasingly
everywhere and states are counting trees
they're counting people they're counting
rivers that does seem it always seems
strange to me that the precious space in
the original Constitution what they gave
so much importance to the census yes
right thing but I guess if you're making
a people yes counting them really man
well and if you're going especially if
you're going to be a democratic people
and you're going to be counting them
later in elections you've got to know
who's that
because otherwise you
you can't you can't have responsible
elections you can't decide who's who's
in a riot for electoral purposes and and
also you know if you want to have
roughly equal sized considerin cease
voting districts you have to know how
many people are aware and all of that
but there are many many other reasons
why States want to count people they
need to know if you want to know how
much money will be raised by attacks you
have to know how many people are her and
what so you start collecting income
statistics if you want to educate people
you have know how many kids there are so
you have to you know and so on there are
lots of reasons so states are developing
these capacities and in the course of
developing these capacities they have to
count things and they have to count
people and so kinds of people become
important they're not so they count men
and women I don't they don't discount
people they count legal they count
Nationals and foreigners and stuff like
that also they increasingly account you
know different kinds of sick people
people who are you know permanently
disabled for example one of their how
many of them there aren't so and that
creates categories as well some of which
become essential eyes so so what they're
doing is in the rise of the nation-state
one of the important things is defining
the nation and and it's very tempting to
have an essentialist a story that says
what makes Germans German is some German
Asst that's in each German something
that's the same in all of them right and
the trouble is that's there isn't going
to be any such thing that distinguishes
Germans from being stains or Serbians or
the French French men and women so I
think nevertheless is a very tempting
thought notice and one of the
fascinating things about this idea is so
it's the nation-state is this idea of a
people with a common something some
sometimes race but often just culture
and traditions who who naturally should
be brought together into a state there
are two things first what was actually
going on was therefore exactly the
opposite of that it was the rise of the
state
that was creating the nation it wasn't
the nation that was creating this there
was the States as a response and to that
means that when this idea spreads around
the world you can actually take a place
like the gold coast colony which became
Ghana which is 80 80 languages or hungry
ethnic groups I mean the counting of
these things is a bit arbitrary you can
take it and turn them into gun hands on
a certain day in 1957 and you can you
can do what has been going on everywhere
else you can make you can make gun hands
tell stories you can tell stories that
fake gun and gun hands and even commands
have to be reminded that in doing that
the British put together two of their
colonies the Togo and Ghana the thing
that's now called Togo is only part of
what was German Tigerland
the British part the part that was given
to the British under the and the League
of Nations mandate at the end of the
First World War when the German colonies
were taken away from the Germans vote
voted to join the new country of Ghana
so it was as clear as anything in the
world that in some sense that what was
going on
was the creation of a state nothing more
constructive than there in plain view
I'm older than Ghana so you know I was
there as it happened and my father who
was a Ghanaian Patriot was was perfectly
aware of all this it didn't he would
have said yes what's the point we yes of
course we have to work together to
become as it were to become gun hands
and that's why he thought that what he
called tribalism was a very dangerous
thing even though he was a loyal member
of his ethnic group he thought that in
the state it was really important not to
discriminate among the peoples of Ghana
so what Garner has done and it's it's
this project that has significantly
succeeded is to create a sense of
Ghanaian identity but it's very hard as
it is with all national identities to
give a simple
story about what that means and as I
said about all identities there's lots
of contest about what it means and
there's contests about who's in and
who's out I mean the boundaries which
thought it will never end will never end
I mean
and so it's precisely because it's never
going to end it is not a solution every
time you find such a fight to say okay
well we're putting these lot in one side
and these lot on the other side they'll
know there'll be no totally agreeable
way of making the sides and as soon as
you've done that within each of the
sides they'll start to be developing
processes and differentiation so the the
organization of African Unity which
became the African Union has insisted
all along with mostly success the main
exception being Eritrea that we were not
to shift the colonial boundaries that
the idea of making more and more groups
because more and more people wanted so
it was not a good idea and it isn't a
good idea so don't go back to the
original tribal no I mean it's not going
to work I mean there are eight or nine
hundred languages in Africa if if a
nation is something with a common
language that's nine hundred countries
right right and that's all going to work
yeah and the United States is a little
bit different than that story right but
not completely different so there's on
the one hand this idea that the United
States is not based on ethnicity but
based on ideas values ideals and ideas
on the other hand there's plenty of
people around today who think that it
kind of is really based on if this right
and the we're at the beginning I mean I
think you know craft car and the lettuce
is American farmer or whatever it's
called says a new race of Americans is
being created using race in this 18th
century rather vague sense but he says
it's being created out of people of all
parts of Europe so he doesn't think that
Native Americans are being made into
this new race and he doesn't think that
the slaves are
going to be and then they're free
descent but he also doesn't think it's
just British he absolutely not
no no give him his name is kefka that
probably wouldn't be a good idea but no
no but they didn't generally i mean of
course we have to remember that in the
in the 19th century people shaped as the
intellectuals of north america were by
European ideas thought of the Irish as a
as a profoundly distinct and in fact
inferior race to to the sort of Anglo
Saxon and Norman descended peoples in in
in other parts of the British Isles so
that notion of racial thinking sort of
shaping how nations develop is not just
an American thing it happens it happens
in in Europe in in France you we have
this anybody who's red asterisks knows
we have the idea of the of the goals and
the francs is it were these two races
together the arrow Scottie Franks and
the present-day goals together make the
great French nation anglo-saxon peasants
Norman Lords make Britain so it's all
nonsense in in in the details you can
show that that's not what happened but
these stories we started with stories
these sorts of stories play a huge role
in shaping these things and in novels
like Ivanhoe in England or all the all
the Walter Scott levels play a role in
shaping ideas about what what England
and Scotland and Ireland and Wales are
and in those things racial ideas play a
central role
people forget perhaps partly because
Ivanhoe's a very long novel so not many
people read it anymore but one of the
central issues in the novel is about a
relationship between a Christian and a
Jewish girl a Jewish woman and again the
issue of their race is sort of central
to thinking about that as is the
relationship between Normans and Saxons
which is also a big racial thing but how
much do our current debates over let's
say identity politics just to use the
buzzword right I mean how much of these
are ways of
framing other kinds of issues and how
much of them really grow organically out
of these actual mm contours of identity
as they grow through time I mean there
are many ways in which ethnic and
religious identities and national
identities intersect with issues that
are just about resources if you if you
look at the collapse of the Yugoslav
state one thing that's going on is that
ancient and pretty low key ethnic
identities become high key and because
they get used to compete for us a
rapidly diminishing cake States
collapsing resources disappearing you
can't fight for them for your family on
your own so you need some and so you
sort of grab for whatever is available
and and it is a grab bag because Muslim
turns out to be one of the categories
you grab bag and that's very different
from servant right but nevertheless
those are the ones that are there
Albanian those the ones that are there
and they get used so that's one thing is
is that they can get used in in what are
essentially competitions for resources
and it's not that there's a natural
tension between Serbs and Croats it's
that if you organize the Serbs and
Croats to compete for resources there
will be a competition between Serbs and
grads but but if you'd organized in some
other way
Catholics versus Orthodox which they
also did to some extent you get
different boundaries and different
groups so yeah it's one way I think one
question is how much ethnic and racial
categories are always to some extent
covers for competition for yeah for
resources I think there's always that so
even if what matters most to you about
your identity as an african-american is
get out culture and traditions in the
black church music whatever you it
cannot but
it cannot but figure somewhat in your
thinking that poverty in the United
States and the distribution of material
resources is very strongly correlated
with racial okay one of the things that
has come out in your discussion is the
idea that these categories have
implications for you know boots on the
ground broadly speaking where the money
goes who gets to vote who gets thrown in
jail and things like that right so for
example there's the there's the
contemporary debate on reparations for
slavery and if someone is African
American in the sense that they were
born in Africa and moved to America they
shouldn't get reparations on slavery
maybe but you know right it does it too
much reify the idea well so I think what
happens so there is this group now
called forgotten what it's called an
American descendants of slaves I think
they call themselves who are making the
point that they're in favor of
reparations but they don't want the
reparations to go to Haitians or
Nigerian Americans they wanted to go to
people who are descended even though the
extent to which blacks are discriminated
against probably is not very much I know
it's not very sensitive it's not very
sensitive no it isn't I mean I think the
whole business of how to think I myself
don't think there's a coherent way of
giving individualized reparations I just
think that doesn't make sense
a significant number of the descendants
of American slaves have passed now under
their now white and also a very large
proportion of American descendants of
slaves are the descendants of slave
owners do so they preserve should
presumably be transferring money to
themselves so I think I think I think
the idea that we can it's one thing to
say that at the moment you can broadly
agree on a rough boundary between
African Americans and other Americans
but already the question of how you
should think about people who's and who
came here black people who came here in
their own lifetimes or people whose
recent recent and descendants of recent
immigrant families who come from places
where there are black people I mean how
should we fit those into that so that's
it yeah there's no sense I mean it's not
a sensible question so it doesn't have a
sensible answer yeah so I say I worry
that the focus on reparations which is
also necessarily backward-looking
distracts us from forward-looking
concerns about making sure that
everybody has an equal and decent shot
well that's that's good let me just
dramatically simplify the world here by
sketching out three different positions
okay and then we can talk about them one
position is the social justice warrior
position which says that you know there
are certain identities certain groups of
people who are just not treated fairly
and we should go to great efforts to fix
that one way or the other
there's then sort of a countervailing
position a hmong this is gonna sound
unfair it's hard for me to say this but
you know white male straight people who
feel like they're the ones who were
actually being picked upon today because
you know they didn't have anything to do
with slavery or anything like that and
their economic situation isn't very good
and why should they be portrayed as the
aggressors here and then there's another
category of people who think that the
entire discussion is wrongheaded in the
sense that we should just be people
right we should pretend that we don't
see race and gender and things like that
and isn't the constant harping on these
identities making things worse for
everybody mm-hmm that's way too
simplistic but does does the kind of
academic understanding of where identity
comes from and the role of plays help us
adjudicate these battles so I think it's
important to distinguish well first of
all whether someone is disadvantaged in
our society correlates with some of
these identity
but it's by no means determined by them
and there are some very very badly of
straight white men in this country and
similarly there's some I'm I suppose
black by American standards and and I'm
and I'm gay so there you are but I can't
pretend to think that I'm not rolling in
all kinds of privilege it's a nice
office it's a nice office I have a nice
job I have a lovely husband you know I
have no reasonable complaints so I'm
sorry but you probably have had some
complaints over the course of you well I
mean people have said racist homophobic
things around me but but I didn't they
weren't in a position to do anything to
me but it's those people so so even
though I so mostly what I meant but
that's key right could you just let them
bounce off in a way that is absolute
less privileged right now I'm very
conscious of the ways internationally I
mean just to sort of be explicit about
this there's obviously a dimension of
class here and the class privilege that
I have is you know I'm in I'm in
Debrett's which is the book of the
British aristocracy my ancestors of my
ancestry and I and my uncle and
great-uncle were kings in the town that
I grew up in so I grew up with enormous
social privilege and that makes it very
easy to kind of water off a duck's back
about some of these things so I don't
and I'm extremely conscious that without
that privilege I couldn't say that the
racial dimension of my identity was was
not a source of problems for me so I and
that's a point about what in the
technical language will be called
intersectionality it's a point about the
fact that these identities come together
in different ways and the total package
of your situation depends on all of them
that's right um it's not and not only
does it depend on all of them it depends
on all them as a physicist would say
nonlinearly yes just the sum of all no
it's how they are interacting with each
other right it's not just a vector sum
it's something way more complicated than
that
so so I have some sympathy if you are a
poor white man struggling to make a
living in a post-industrial
context the world is changing around and
the world around you and the world
doesn't seem terribly interested in
helping you I am sympathetic with a view
that our society is not doing what it
should for you and and I was sympathetic
with that view before some of those
people voted for Donald Trump and was
already saying this so um and we still
are afterward even though we wish they
hadn't voted for Donald yes yes yes and
we it's still the case that that's a
genuine it's a real argument problem in
our society on the other hand
understanding that there are real needs
there that these are our fellow citizens
with real needs doesn't mean that I
can't say that if they're racist that's
wrong or that if they think that because
we don't have legal segregation anymore
there's no problem for black people to
complain about that just seems to me you
know there's very good reason to doubt
there there's lots of evidence in labor
economics for example that that's just
not true
and I can't pretend to agree with them
about that because I think they're wrong
about it and I think they may well be
wrong about some of the things they
think about what's happened in gender as
well is which they may not be happy
about so I think we have to so that's
one set of issues we've got to be yes we
should disaggregate we should be careful
and we should pay attention to all the
problems weights not it's not impossible
to keep track of more than one problem
and the problems of class in our society
are very very serious and they are of
course they interact with racial
questions but they're but the problems
of the people at the bottom of the money
social capital and cultural capital
hierarchies are real problems and and
and they're and the majority of those
people are white because black people
are minority in this country and even if
you include Hispanics who are a
significant minority now
and more than blacks larger numbers it's
still the case that some of the most
serious most of the serious problems at
the bottom are significantly faced by
white people as well so when people
complain about identity politics having
distracted us from to ask politics I'm
inclined to agree though I should point
out the class politics is a kind of
identity politics do is it their own
identity and the point is we should be
keeping track of all of the ways in
which all of the identities intersect
with questions of justice and fairness
so we've done a bad job of that I think
in keeping I you know I as I say I feel
deeply that we've let down a significant
part of the population that's white
because well for many reasons part of it
is to do with the general I'm afraid
corruption of our political system began
because a significant part of the
problem these people face is the result
of decisions that are good for business
decisions to offshore jobs or to use
robots which I which are increased
productivity and and and childr value
and all the things that you care about
if you're running a company and because
those people want to be allowed to do
those things which i think is fine
provided some of the wealth created by
doing those things is spent on making
lives okay for the people who are
deceased lives are disrupted by these
things it's true that we don't have a
problem unemployment at the moment in
this country since the return of jobs
after 2008 but but we do have a problem
of satisfying significant well-paid jobs
hmm yeah and we're a very rich country
and we could do something about that and
we haven't and I really do think that
part of the reason is that it's easier
to make gestures around race and gender
gestures because we have still got huge
inequalities around both of them than it
is to make the Jemez gestures around
Oh make real significant change around
around these economic inequality well I
think this is a key point because I'm
sort of personally sympathetic to those
who want to highlight the ways in which
people are treated unfairly because of
their identity whether it's gender or
race or whatever Oh class or class but
as you just point out I think it's very
worth emphasizing that can be a cheap
and easy route to take when the reality
is more complicated and I think you've
got to be careful of tokenism it's an
important fact that a significant part
of the integration of the elite
universities in this country in respect
to race has been done by bringing in
very very elite black people mm-hmm
it's still a real problem and by the way
we haven't done a terrific legal a good
job of bringing in non elite white
people into to the universities either
our universities are a significant part
of the problem in the intergenerational
transfer of class privilege in the
United States if I understand it
correctly I've been told that
affirmative action which has all sorts
of problems but it's one of the cheapest
and most efficient ways of creating
black middle class yes take a bunch of
black people who wouldn't have gone to
college otherwise you said in their
really good colleges they go back and
everything improves but it's much easier
to sort of do that along racial
categories than the long class category
yes because the thing I mean I think
many of the African Americans who were
integrated into the say the the elite
universities in starting in the late 60s
would say that the universities could
have done a better job and by the way at
that point there was a little bit more
class variety among the first generation
for some reason among the first
generations but they I think they might
say that these places could have done a
better job of changing to meet them
not making them feel unwelcome
by just going on the way they welcome to
our wasp but unclear yes exactly and
just taking making I mean what's what's
interesting is that is that it's only in
the 60s remember that systematic
discrimination against Jews really stops
in these institutions so it's not like
it's not like there's been no problems
for people other than black people
health tech tried to hire Albert
Einstein but it was just such an
anti-semitic place yes wouldn't go right
so and and yeah he did fine at the
Institute for Advanced Study he did call
the concentration camp at one point for
them yeah there's this more than enough
anti-semitism out there also right not
as bad a California so I think the I
think the but what's interesting sorry
what I can say about that is that the
way in which the first generations of
Jewish intellectuals who were admitted
to places like Columbia and Harvard and
so on responded was to some extent to
just enter the wasp cultural thing so
you if you were not an American it would
not have occurred to you that LAN or
trilling I think was Jewish and what's
interesting is that there's a later
generation among whom I think we can
include someone like Harold Bloom who
who who did the thing of saying I'm
coming as a Jew and I'm not well this is
always a tricky thing with identity you
know the extent to which you assimilate
versus assert yes you're right and and
both of these things herbal you know and
and you know in the end you want to
create a world in which people can do
what they wanted that's right and
allowed to assimilate that's what if
that's what they want and so you don't
you don't criticize you don't say oh
you're an Oreo or a banana
whatever the insults are for people who
are you know wait that doesn't wait on
the inside but but but you also the
institution benefits
if it adapts if it says ok we've got
different kinds of people here coming
what do we need to do and I think we've
done some of that for race in some
places and an african-american studies
which is a field that I've worked in a
lot has been part of that and I'm proud
of that I think that's a useful
contribution but but we've done a
terrible job of dealing with the class
problem in terms of making the place
more welcoming if you it's just a simple
set of questions I mean if you are if
you build a university around the
assumption that everybody has enough
money that they don't need to work while
they're in college you'll get one kind
of institution if you recognize as we do
here at NYU that many most of our
students are working and have to work
because they wouldn't have enough money
to eat otherwise I would buy their books
then you have to change the place and
you you have to think about what hours
you teach at how many credits it's
reasonable to expect people to get in
the Ennis and so on you have to change
or you have to have enough money to say
you don't have to work if you don't want
to which is what Princeton does for
instance very rich institution so nobody
has to work yeah basically I mean you
know if your parents can afford it you
wish you they expect you to contribute
but if they can't they don't and you're
not required to you're supposed to be
pretty rich as an institution to pull
that off yes well it's the richest
pursued an institution in the world so
jolly well ought to be doing it but but
it's but we know we can't do that we're
the largest private university in the
United States and we have a tiny
endowment so we're tuition driven and we
have to be very attentive to the fact
that our tuition is a huge part of the
investment that families of our students
will be making in them in the whole of
their lives it's the most it's the
largest and we should keep it as small
as we can while consistently you know
being being a great University so I
think I'm with the people who criticize
our failure to think about those
questions
but I think the thought that we're not
thinking about them because we're
thinking about something else and and so
that we should stop thinking about other
forms of injustice just seems a non
sequitur to me is a deflection strategy
yes it's just say we should do we should
do we should you know do anything we can
to to make our institutions and this is
a point about universities but of course
it's a general point about about about
the social institutions of our society
that they should be open to people of
all the kinds that there are in our
society and and on roughly equal terms
well so there is there's certainly this
attitude the possible stance one can
take you wrote a wonderful book that I
really enjoyed cosmopolitanism I'm you
know cosmopolitanism in certain circles
is now used sort of as a quasi
anti-semitic slur but I think we want to
reclaim this as a positive thing to be
but it's not an unproblematically
positive thing to be mean what is your
sales pitch for cosmopolitanism so I
think of course imposed ism is combining
two thoughts what the expression
cosmopolitan Greek means citizen of the
world so one thought is just them that
there's some important sense in which
each of us should think of all the other
people in the world as our fellow
citizens of something this is a metaphor
because there isn't the world state so
we're not literally fellow citizens of
anything but we should treat each other
in ways that are somewhat like the ways
we treat fellow citizens which means I
assume that we should care for what
happens to them and try to shape the
world so that they can do well just as
we can do well and that maybe not
everybody in every group of citizens
shares this but we should be sort of
interested in them not just in in sort
of making their lives better but in what
they're like wanting to get to know them
so that's one one thing and that second
the second thing is that that's wanting
to get to know them is important because
they're different some of them from us
and that's fine
we don't need them to become like us
what I can do this it can be in fact
more interesting to live in a world
where not everyone's the same I paint
the John Stuart Mill makes beautifully
an unlimited that we we profit from
other people's what he called
experiments of living we in this country
we have the Swedish health care model to
think about in deciding how what we're
going to do if they hadn't done that
experiment we wouldn't know anything
about it it would all be theoretically
will be done by economists and then
probably be pretty pretty bad less we've
know a great deal less but than then by
constructing a priori theories of these
matters so that's the two things is is
the now the universality so I set the
slogan is universality plus difference
the universality thing has elements that
I think a compulsory morally compulsory
you you you have moral obligations to
every human being also to animals but
that has a complication that I will
avoid from now on you have obligations
to other human beings and in
particularly have obligations not to
harm them not to create not to do things
in the world that cause serious harm to
people elsewhere but I don't think the
second thing the thing of taking
pleasure and difference is morally
compulsory I think if you want to hive
yourself off if you want to go if you
want to be an Amish farmer in
Pennsylvania and you don't want to
interact with what they called the
Americana the Americans around them I
think you have to be free to do that and
if you want to live in the letting the
others live their lives yes and you want
to be ultra-orthodox in Jerusalem as
long as you're not throwing stones at
people who are driving on the Sabbath
which some of them do unfortunately
that's fine so so so the total package I
don't think can be argued to be morally
compulsory the first part of the package
is compulsory that's just morality and
it includes respects for human rights
and all those other things the pitch for
taking the whole package it's just that
life's well toot there are two pitches
one is an instrumental piece
we need some Cosmopolitan's because we
have to interact we've got global
warming we've got a whole bunch of
problems got pandemics one planet one
planet we and and and we're
interconnected ecologically health-wise
I like to remind my students that every
year somebody collects influenza viruses
in rural China so that we have a flu
vaccine by the time they get here right
that's a very complicated international
thing and it's done by people it'd be
much less likely to happen if nobody was
interested nobody here was interested in
there nobody there was interested in
here so there's an instrumental reason
but I think there's also just a sort of
gooey sauce a pleasure a reason there
namely that if you think about what one
way to get at this is to think about
what are the great aesthetic objects
that we care about if we care about
aesthetic objects there are things like
music which is fantastically
transnational in its sources and effects
and I mean popular music but I also mean
Beethoven you know handle is the Royal
Fireworks that Handel wrote for German
is the British royal family has he was a
he was the he was a composer in Britain
he was employed in Britain favorite
global example probably the most famous
Japanese poet is basho mm-hmm Basho
writes in a script invented by the
Chinese and belongs to religion invented
by the Indians because he's a Zen
Buddhist
no China no no India no basho right and
no cross and no cross cultural stuff
know my mother writing haiku
as I was growing up because she had
discovered a show and thought he was
wonderful part so Shakespeare's most
famous plays about a Danish Prince not
an English Prince so
that the things that the things we care
about in the cultural domain
spontaneously cross boundaries steal
borrow appropriate whatever you whatever
you want to call well I was gonna I was
gonna mention you know there are there's
the darker side of cultural
appropriation right which is more about
sort of caricature or even disrespecting
other cultures and I I kind of I want to
say that I love cultural appropriation I
love it when cultures mix and interact
and inspire each other but again in the
sense of absolutely understanding those
who are blatantly against it because
it's it's it can be so badly right this
is one of those places where I think the
sort of boring distinctions that
philosophers make really useful and
helpful and get people to see things
more clearly
so the word appropriation is not
terribly useful to talk about somebody
just intruder in blackface that's really
whose culture was he born within
property he wasn't taking anything for
anybody he was just representing people
in a disrespectful way that's not
appropriation and if if he had done it
for the purpose of suppose he had been
dressing up for that purpose in order to
play a role in a performance that was
meant to make a point about racism we
would not have a problem with it so
sorry some people would well some people
would but that's because they're
confused about the distinction between
or that they're not keeping track of the
fact that some ways of taking things
that either are made by or represent
other people are disrespectful and
others armed and if you once and and one
kind of disrespect is exploitation so if
I don't know whether you know whether
Paul Simon's use of become music from
South Africa was good or bad for the
people there
sang in the choir that work with him
economically but if it wasn't it should
have been yeah yes but that's but if it
wasn't that isn't an argument that the
resulting music is a bad thing that's an
argument about the badness of how it was
made and there's no reason not to listen
to it even once you discover the head
because its existence as music is
different from its status as a sort of
product of a moral price so in some
sense and there can be perfectly
acceptable things that might be labelled
cultural appropriation but there's a
sensitivity that needs to yes that's
right and and you know when people where
I mean I I'm old enough that when I was
a kid with my grandmother in England I
watched a television program called the
black and white minstrel show in which
in which English people fight white in
English people perform in [ __ ] yeah
black faces with big big red lips and
the music was great as it happens at
least I thought I enjoyed it but and I
was innocent enough that it didn't occur
to me how ridiculous it was that they
had to put those faces on in order to do
it so that tradition of you know sort of
[ __ ] blackface is obviously horrible
and to continue it is to be insensitive
to the badness of that history but but
not all sharing and borrowing and taking
and even stealing is like that and
what's wrong with theft is that it's
theft there's no sharing right yeah so I
think we don't want to stop the flow
right well sorry I don't want to stop
the flow I know I people do want to stop
the flow and I'm sad about that because
as I say I think if I think about the
things my mother appropriated Asante
Anansie stories in order to give
American and British children something
wonderful to read and I know a lot of
African Americans of my generation who
remember reading them my mother's
version of these African stories my
white mother's version when they were
kids so
I just can't see anything wrong with
that and because it was done with love
and respect and and with acknowledgement
she didn't pretend that she'd made them
up well this idea I mean you just said
you know we shouldn't then you change
you too I shouldn't and I think that
brings up probably the last big point I
want to get on the table which is you
talk in the book about the role of
positivism logical logical positivism or
just positive I think I call it positive
because anyway the the important part of
it for you was the fact value
distinction and you know how values are
not quite fixed by the facts and when
you're trying to be good cosmopolitan
one of the questions it arises is how
judgy we can be about what goes on in
other cultures there's there's an
argument made by various dictatorships
around the world that you Westerners
shouldn't judge us because we're a
different culture and I'm very much in
favor of judging them in fact Sharon
Street when are your colleagues here at
NYU is very influential for my way of
thinking about how you can not think
that morality is fixed by the universe
or objectively out there you can
construct it but it still exists then
you can use it to judge other people
good so I believe this too that's why I
can't get a visa to go to China because
I criticize them you believe it believe
it out loud though I'm hoping that
they'll change their minds because I
would love to go to China because I'm
interested in what's going on in China
and I'm not particular interested in
destroying the political system that I
wish it were more generous to its
critics so I think the way to think
about it is the way I think about it
anyway is what the Cosmopolitan
recommends is a kind of cross-cultural
conversation which means that you're
more likely to get your criticisms right
if you haven't been listening to people
if you're not paying attention to what
they're really doing if you don't really
care about them you will criticize them
but mostly your criticisms will miss the
mark so for example to take a case that
everybody wants to bring up things to do
with female genital cutting there's no
point in criticizing that practice in
the society unless you know what they do
and
unless you know what the the women
who've been through it think about it
even if you think they're in a state of
false consciousness you need to know
what they're thinking and the fact is
that what we call what people call a
female circumcision as a practice ranges
enormous ly in what it is in some of it
involves just a Nick to the labia and
I'm against any kind of unnecessary
physical mutilation of children but but
it's not very serious veronik incision
removal of the clitoris and sewing out
the labia that's a very serious bad idea
and it's bad for reason but here again
this is something to get across the
badness of it one of the things you have
to notice is that it's bad for fertility
and most of the societies which practice
it care about fertility so there's a
thing about it that they should care
about but you won't know that if you
haven't been paying attention so and I
think that respectful interventions from
outside have made this is true with
female genital cutting in Senegambia in
West Africa the successful interventions
have been being been by people who came
in and didn't wag their fingers but they
just talked to people they talked about
the medical staff they talked about
human rights and the rights of children
they didn't even directly talk and they
waited until the moment when somebody
said I think maybe that means that we
shouldn't be and then they said okay if
that's what you think let's figure out
how to make it happen let's try and
persuade everybody in this village but
let's not do it on our own because we
marry the kids in the next village
our daughters marry their sons their
sons marry our daughters
we need to persuade them as well
otherwise we won't build to marry right
I mean simple point but again to know
that you have to know something about
the lives of these people well that's a
very good point I mean it's a it's okay
to be judgy it's okay to think that the
practices of other cultures are wrong
but it requires a certain amount of work
yes and both in order to make sure that
your criticism is car
and to be in a position to do anything
at all effective to try and persuade
them to do it the other way in in a book
that I wrote about about honor I put I
pointed out that the end of the practice
of foot binding in China was
significantly brought about by the
presence in China of evangelical
Christian missionaries who were enormous
ly respectful of Chinese civilization
but thought this practice which isn't
particularly unchristian it's just a bad
practice was a bad practice and they
persuaded they got Chinese
intelligentsia members of the Chinese
intelligentsia very famous know people
like kang youwei to see this and they
Chinese then organized anti foot binding
societies as they had organized anti
opium societies and and over again over
generation that went away over 20 years
it went from you know ninety percent in
many places to sort of basically zero
and lots of places at different times in
different places but very very Swift so
the Cosmopolitan's are going to be
better at doing that the cribbing judgy
because they're more likely to be
interested in what's actually going on
you might learn something
yeah and also you're listening yeah
you're not just talking and the fact is
I want the Chinese to be able to
criticize our prison system which is way
more incarceration than theirs
percentage-wise and and at least in Hong
Kong no not in much of China the prisons
of pretty good in terms of conditions
they're not Sweden but they're
definitely better than many prisons in
Louisiana so I think we need the kosst
amojan wants to listen as well as talk
and in that conversation we will be
judged and that's fine
that's part of the point oh yeah that's
part of the bargain yes and and also
it's part of what we get because because
maybe we're doing something wrong almost
certainly we're doing something yes for
sure we are and and and it won't be
evident to us it won't be as evident to
us as it might be to someone looking
outside though the outsider has to be
attentive to what we're actually up to
to the outsider who just waves a hand
that says Oh Americans do something
something anything
Lock their parents up in they lock their
grandparents up in old people's home so
that's that's not a really a very I mean
that's not a very good description of
what's going on do you think this kind
of strategy will be helpful in spreading
democracy around the world is that too
much - um I think it's the only strategy
that might help in spreading though one
of the things about democracy and and by
the way the language Human Rights is
that on the whole once you get them into
the hands of ordinary people they think
they're a good idea it's it's the
government that may not be so keen on
democracy but people usually think it
would be a good idea to be consulted and
a good idea to play a role and a good
idea to have their rights protected by
their own state and if their own state
doesn't know knowing that their state
will be criticized by other states if it
doesn't and just as their state should
criticize other states when they don't
do things right for their own citizens
so I think but that means of course that
it's going to have to be um whatever you
know the forms of democracy are going to
be different they're going to work
they're gonna have different backgrounds
different traditions different
challenges the the kind of issues that
arise in a multi-ethnic society like
Ghana where there's no majority
ethnicity are different from the kinds
that arise in the society which are
multiracial and there's a dominant
ethnic racial group right those are just
different and what you have to do in
designing your democracy to deal with
the problems is different in those two
cases but also it depends upon the
history the Germans I think not
unreasonably violate a principle that is
embedded in our law about freedom of
expression by not allowing people to
publish copies of mine come free given
the history yeah I don't think that's a
crazy decision but it would be - I think
it would be wrong to stop Americans
having access to my income even though
some of them are going to use it to form
all right groups that well you know
draws swastikas on synagogues and do
idiotic things like that
so I so I think but that again you know
that conversation across societies about
what free expression is and and
recognizing this different in different
places we can't expect Abu Dhabi to
immediately go to the regime of
regulation of pornography that we have
in the United States it's just not gonna
work for them right their histories
different cultures their cultures
different nation to different and so but
but we should try and despite the
mistake should try to sign us that that
on the whole their society will work
better and will be fair to its people if
they allow them pretty broad freedom to
say what they wanted I like it all seems
very reasonable everyone's talking to
each other enjoying food from different
face yes it gives me some optimism that
the world can become a more cosmopolitan
yes and just remember the the BBC I'm
not gonna remember the exact numbers but
the BBC did a poll a couple of years ago
around the world asking people if they
thought they were citizens of the world
in fact they asked them in my view a
ridiculous question which was I are you
more of a citizen the world everywhere
of your country which is the wrong
question because the whole point about
cousin Pollin ism is it requires you to
be loyal to some local things as well
because that's what you're bringing to
the cosmopolitan conversation but anyway
they they found that in many countries
including the United States a
significant number of people were
willing to say yes even to that bizarre
question so I don't know how many would
have said yes if they'd asked the right
question which is are you a citizen of
the world as well as a citizen of your
country but in many countries it was a
majority the population that said they
felt more like citizens of the world
than they did in their own country right
now some of them in places like Nigeria
where you can understand that because
Nigerian state is a mess but some of
them Swiss I can't remember I wish I
could remember the details but it's
worth looking up but so I think there is
a as I say we can't require everybody to
do this we can't expect everybody to do
this but it's okay but that's fine
that's that's part of the cosmopolitan
thing is that we're cool with difference
we I would be happy if an Amish family
were willing to let me come and spend
time and see what their life was like
but they're not
they don't like and and I can see well I
don't particularly want you know do I
want some well-intentioned French
straight person to say can I come and
spend time with your gay family in order
to see what gay that seems like a weird
thing so the the thing is that the it's
the it has to be a conversation among
equals for it to be really productive
and the world is full of inequalities
and that makes it really hard
yeah well Kwame Anthony Appiah
conversations among equals are always
great things and maybe this is not
equals but it anyway we're on the same
page thanks so much for being on the
podcast it was great very nice talk to
you
[Music]
you
[Music]